middle management is the hardest job in
any organization because when you're jr.
your only job is really to do your job
that's it and you get trained how to do
your job I mean you all have to be
licensed and go to school and learn how
to do the job of being an accountant and
if you're really good at it you
eventually you get promoted and you
eventually get promoted to position
where you're now responsible for the
people who do the job you used to do but
the problem is they don't give us any
training how to do that you know and
senior people are thinking about
entirely different things they're
thinking about the firm thinking about
strategy and the problem is so you have
this middle group that's in this sort of
weird mix where they're not there they
have to be strategic but not majority
strategic and they they have to be
tactical but they're not majority
tactical and they have to translate
what's going up here to down there and
down here to up here and and most things
break in the middle because I'll meet
firms where the leadership is amazing
and they're visionary and they care
about people and they want to do the
right thing and then I go down to the
frontline and they're like yeah this
place is the worst
and so I'm like what happened between
here and there and it's the middle most
things break in the middle and so I
think there are two there are two there
are two factors one is we don't train
people how to lead right so as I said
before when you were junior we're we
have to know what to do we just do our
jobs we'd be good at it and as we become
leaders in this middle management we're
now transitioning to this job we're now
responsible for the people who do the
job we used to do but nobody is teaching
us listening nobody's teaching us
communication skills nobody's teaching
as effective confrontation nobody's
teaching us how to give and repeat
receive feedback nobody's actually
teaching us leadership so this is why we
get managers and not leaders and like
you would never ask somebody to do
anything in accounting without showing
them how to do it
ever bad idea all right
so why on earth do we think that we can
just promote someone to a leadership
position and expect that they know what
to do without showing them how to do it
so that's problem number one is is that
is the rule is the total vacuum in some
cases or just really minimal amounts of
leadership training
and it needs to be robust the other
problem that I come across very often is
I get some really wonderful self-taught
leaders of middle management they're
reading books they're going to
conferences themselves they're watching
TED Talks I mean there's students of
leadership they have mentors I mean
they're really making a go of it and
they complain that the that the senior
management all they care about is is the
quarterly earnings and so that problem
we have there is they're trying so hard
to do the right thing but management
really doesn't care so that's the
opposite right and in those cases I
recommend that they the right thing to
do
I mean quitting is always an option but
that's not the not necessarily the best
option or the first option but I always
recommend to be the leader you wish you
had which is they'll I get the question
it is one of the if not the most common
question I get which is what do I do
when I'm trying to do the right thing
and and my boss for my boss's boss or my
boss's boss's boss just don't get it you
know all they care about is money before
people and and the answer is you can't
control what you can't control so
worried about the people around you
worried about the people to the sides of
you the level below you even a level
above you and you be the leader you wish
you had what you start to find in those
pockets is these magical little diamonds
in the rough up here we we worked with a
large a large technology company and we
worked with a group where that's exactly
what we did we we developed this whole
leadership thing just for this little
group in the middle and yes they started
to do better and their numbers went
better and the group expanded and blah
blah blah all the things you'd expect to
happen but one thing we didn't expect is
that the phone started ringing off the
hook from other people in the firm
asking can I get a job in your group
because when the people who worked in
this group would go out for lunch with
their friends who works in other groups
you know how's work today amazing
different stories different stories and
all of a sudden words spread across this
80,000 person company and this was only
a group of 150 people word spread across
this 80,000 person company that
everybody was trying to get into this
group which is because it was they
wanted to work in it because he had good
leadership
[Music]